let's take a closer look at the tanks um
what's what could be sent what are they
what what would it mean yeah so um if
you can Ukraine's going to move from
defense to offense it needs to have
tanks that that's a simple one tanks are
really complex but listen to the Janet
and John version Tank's all about how
much defensive armor you've got in other
words how survival and how powerful your
gun is at the front of it modern tanks
are blistering with armored powerful
guns but the t-64 which is used in
Ukraine was designed in the 60s was
really obsolete by the 80s and just
doesn't hack it and if rumors to be
believed there's rooms about 3 000 of
these tanks have been destroyed in the
battlefield so they're not the answer
and the sort of tanks that are being
considered at the moment if we go
through it with a sort of top trumps way
um Challenger 2 from the UK uh enter
service in the 90s I think we've got a
picture of it in a moment though
challenge two
um it's got trouble man it's got a rifle
Baron so it's very very capable modern
tank the downside it's got bespoke
ammunition and the factory that makes
you I understand is closed down at the
moment there's also very limited numbers
of these available and therefore the
offer that the UK has made is only five
percent of the number that president
zielinski wants and he presents he
probably wants one mark of tank not just
loads of different ones if we look at
the Abrahams which is the American model
this Center service in the 1980s again
it's got chobamama very powerful there's
over 9 000 of these been made over the
years there's plenty available there
downside is it's it's ruthless with fuel
it gets through fuel very quickly any
tank is less than one mile a gallon but
this is 50 worse than any of the modern
tanks on the battlefield
um so and also the time taken to get
these tanks from America in and then the
training it's quite complicated leopard
two is the final one entered service in
1979 uh there are over 2 000 of these in
service with over 13 different countries
so it does meet the numbers game it's
got a good good gun good good armor the
only negative is that the only way that
people can give them on is if the
Germans provide this export license so
in in summary the challenge of two is
good not enough numbers both the
Abraham's hands the leper 2 meet the
requirements almost certainly the
politics behind this is if America was
to provide the Abraham's tank then it's
providing the one bit of offensive
capability to Ukraine that's going to be
fighting Russia and that starts to play
to the Russian agenda if this is a
battle between an America and Russia
whereas if the leper 2 was to put into
theater it becomes more coherent with
the European support for the Ukrainian
position okay
um Lloyd Austin talking in Germany has
said that this is a decisive moment
Ukraine has asked for 300 tanks
if they're given to them would that be a
turning point for the war do you think
the short answer is yes the difficulty
is how many you need and that's almost
an impossible question to answer most
military pundits are talking about 300
being the right sort of number but
whether or not in the future they want
more that's another matter the real key
question is whether they get delivered
in time because it's not just about
getting the tanks in it's having all the
training that's required in time for the
spring offense here but most military
commentators say we're really up against
the stops now the reason this will be
decisive as well is the kremlin's been
issuing threats to the West over the
last few days because it realizes what a
big impact these modern tanks could have
and it just shows why today's meeting in
Ramstein is just so important it's not
about one of the old meetings of lots of
Nations throwing weapons on the table to
try and help Ukraine this is a decisive
moment of moving Ukraine from the
defense to the offense offense and
creating the foundations for the next
chapter of this war